the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
i remember myself telling the chief
you know a lot of guys gonna die today
tonight on politics now 20 years since 9
11 a former new york city firefighter
shares his experience at ground zero
plus
it's very surreal that 20 years have
gone by
an fbi agent recalls why the tragedy hit
home for him twice
[Music]
this is a moment in history this is a
physical artifact of a moment in history
that i think has to be preserved
and we'll take you to the 911 memorial
that is now at unlv and how it's
preserving our city's history for future
generations
from 8 news now
this is politics now
you very much for joining us tonight on
politics now i'm john langler and
tonight we mark 20 years since the
terror attacks of september 11th the
special edition of politics now will
focus on the tragedy the heroes and the
fallout and we start with one las vegas
local who was on the front lines that
day the i-team's vanessa murphy here
with his story vanessa john frank
pizarro dealt with the grief of losing
fellow firefighters on 9 11. he also was
part of the recovery effort to find
their bodies he lives with the pain and
trauma every day
of telling the chief
you know a lot of guys going to die
today
frank pizarro remembers the ride from
his new york city firehouse to the world
trade center on september 11 2001 where
destruction continued because there was
a verizon building
that was a block over and we had gone
into search after the first two towers
have come down
and five minutes after we got out of
that that thing came down in the days
and months that followed we went digging
through the pile
you know hoping to find anything or
anybody he was part of search efforts it
was powerful because
we would find say a fireman from a
specific house
and all work would stop and we would
call
that firehouse
so they could come and bring him out of
the hole and so it was it was
a sight to be seen the aisle would line
up and everybody would stand attention
and salute as he would be carried out
and this happened over and over and over
again 20 years later he remains proud to
wear the uniform i would do it all over
again you know it's it's probably the
best job in the world
and
i lost a lot of friends
and brothers and um
that i'll never forget he retired in
2017 and then moved to las vegas like
many first responders at ground zero he
says he has health issues including lung
disease but that doesn't keep him from
his passion i decided that i'm gonna
sing until i can't sing anymore
it's not as easy as it used to be
but i give everything i got
and i'm gonna sing until the last note
comes out
from 9 11 tributes in southern nevada to
the world series in new york pizarro
continues to share his voice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
pizarro started a charity to help
remember fallen firefighters we have
more information at
eightnewsnow.com vanessa has an
incredible voice we've seen him at the
memorials here in las vegas for some
time vanessa you and i are both from uh
back east from the new york area and 9
11 means a lot to us personally but you
in particular have a personal connection
to 9 11 and someone special to you
yeah my grandfather helped some of the
911 victims as you mentioned like many
las vegas locals i didn't grow up here
i'm originally from new york that's
where most of my family is including my
grandfather he's in queens so we talked
about his experience on zoom
well it's like it's like a war zone this
is my grandfather dr james mazzara at 83
years old he's now retired but on
september 11 2001 he was chief of
clinical cardiology at st vincent's
hospital in new york city
we were a mile and a half north of the
twin towers
he was heading a fellowship program at
the time and he recalls receiving word
during a teaching conference the chief
resident came in and said a plane had
crashed into the one of the twin towers
they prepared to treat patients the team
first thought what was unfolding was an
accident but then the second plane hit
the second tower that's when things
looked
more ominous
at the time patients arrived with trauma
injuries from debris that had fallen
some had respiratory symptoms many were
covered in dust he says this continued
through most of the day and he slept at
the hospital that night things start
started to slow down
and that was a sign to us
that things were not looking good the
realization many did not survive these
were you know innocent people almost 3
000 non-military people who had their
lives destroyed their families
changed forever and many of those
families posted notes as they searched
for their loved ones hoping they would
turn up safe at places like saint
vincent's it was a tragic time
like many new yorkers and americans for
my grandfather the 20th anniversary of 9
11 stirs up emotions and memories that
are difficult to accept
from
the floor we were on in the hospital we
could actually see one of the towers
with billowing smoke
uh coming from it
so i mean i'll always i'll always
remember that
makes you think how fragile life is
saint vincent's hospital was a level one
trauma center considering that and its
close process proximity to the world
trade center that's why many patients
were brought there the hospital closed
in 2010 and that's when my grandfather
retired today at the site of the world
trade center there's a 911 memorial end
museum john back to you vanessa it is
well worth visiting as well thank you
for the story
well after the attacks our own new york
new york became a memorial in las vegas
mementos left right there on las vegas
boulevard 20 years later the memorial is
now stored safely over at unlv the
i-team's david charns took a look inside
david
john you may remember those thousands of
t-shirts hats and other items left right
in front of the replica of the statue of
liberty our neighbors and tourists
started leaving there with their
thoughts and their prayers on the night
of september 11th and now 20 years later
they are little moments of our history
frozen in time
it was truly a
unique memorial and they didn't
want these to be lost stored safely
inside a library at unlv so each t-shirt
was is individually identified i believe
it's about 400 boxes
5 000 t-shirts peter michelle is the
keeper of a collection of cotton
memories of one of america's darkest
days cataloged and saved we document
history in whatever way we possibly can
it's what las vegas and visitors left
behind
a memorial at our version of new york
our lady liberty and the city she calls
home if you were firemen visiting las
vegas you would have had this t-shirt
these are individual hats from fire
companies t-shirts hats
patches and poems all too soon the
cowards strike firefighters police and
tourists alike leaving a piece of them
for all to see
to see
and to share to share their own grief as
a fireman in thinking about firemen in
new york city when you actually hold up
a t-shirt and hold a t-shirt you
understand somebody was wearing that
t-shirt that belonged to an individual
fireman somewhere who also puts his life
in danger every day the question for the
hotel is what do we do with these 20
years later they remain unwashed and
untouched just like they were that day
and in the months and now years after
with hand written
not forgotten a glimpse of how we
grieved
in order to learn in the years to come
this is a physical artifact of a moment
in history that i think has to be
preserved
and john part of the preservation
includes educating younger generations
about what happened that day by seeing
just how our community paid their
respects
now 20 years ago john yeah david it's an
ongoing lesson and i think especially
now 20 years since the tragedy a lot of
us think back to where we were at that
time i was in college i was a senior in
upstate new york where were you on 9 11
right we sort of look at the you know we
all aged in 20 years i was 12
and in eighth grade and i remember
getting to school late on that day i'm
from the new england area and
unfortunately there were people uh
students at my school whose
families were on some of those planes
because they came from boston and we
just sort of watched it all unfold on tv
and you know it just was such a such a
difficult time and it's hard to believe
that it has been two decades since then
yeah my father used to work in the world
trade center many years ago we all sort
of remember where we were at that time
david you also spoke with the local fbi
agent who just started at the agency
when he was called to work on september
11. right he was 29 at the time and what
started as a day that he was to bury his
father turned into one to secure and
investigate our country's largest crime
scene
good morning 64 degrees at 8 o'clock
it's tuesday september 11. the sky was
crystal blue there wasn't a cloud in the
sky and it seemed like the most bluest
sky i've ever seen september 11 2001
means a few things to christopher
lamanna it's very surreal that 20 years
have gone by it's the day he said
goodbye to his father my dad had passed
away two days earlier
from battling lung cancer and the day
terrorists struck his hometown lamanna
now a special agent with the fbi in las
vegas then 29 was about a year into the
job with the fbi in new york city we
were scheduled to bury him
on that tuesday 9 11. a regular
september tuesday
turning into a nightmare some of my
relatives had indicated that they heard
a plane had
struck the world trade center at the
funeral parlor i had noticed a number of
fbi agents but when we got to the church
they were all gone soon after he too
left his family said goodbye and got to
work i remember getting home changing
out of my suit
putting on you know other clothes that
were a little more comfortable because i
didn't know what i was going to be doing
i've been inside the world trade center
so it's very personal
to me because i've walked on the streets
around you know where the world trade
center stood
i had memories there as the towers fell
lamanna rushed downtown i had to go down
there because i knew there were people
down there people that i knew including
his co-worker beth near one of the
towers when it collapsed the debris the
darkness that
enveloped them so quickly
she said she could barely breathe she
saw a glint of an nypd officer shield
and she grabbed his arm and they worked
their way out of
the area
she was covered from head to toe she
escaped and years later became lamana's
wife
now every september 11th is a time to
remember those moments leading to a
lifetime together moments from that day
and moments with those we've lost i
think about my dad every year
on 9 11 there's a time to mourn but that
was a time for service
i know my dad would have felt the same
way
and lamanna has a photo of the new york
skyline with the twin towers hanging up
in his home he says that he spent months
working 12-hour days 12 yeah 12-hour
days 12-hour shifts investigating the
attacks and the terrorists for a real
long time and right now he's working
here at the fbi's las vegas office
office john david thank you very much
the 911 attacks led to the wars in
afghanistan and iraq years later many
veterans are still dealing with health
issues from those wars like cancer and
toxic burn pits may be to blame
your concern is obviously the needs of
the mission and less so like that you're
thinking about those after effects the
evidence suggests that it's probably my
time in the service
matthew wetnall served eight years in
active duty including two tours in
afghanistan he survived an ied blast but
not the air the actual air around him
scans showed a golf ball-sized mass in
the back of his brain and another on his
lung burn pits like the ones you see
there were loaded up by the military
with things like lithium-ion batteries
and just set on fire and they created a
toxic brew for people like retinol
soldiers and servicemen and women to
breathe in
there has been a push for legislation to
try and help veterans suffering from
those cancers but it hasn't passed yet i
spoke with our washington dc
correspondent alex simone
there's been discussion about this on
capitol hill for a long time there have
been some pretty uh public discussions
about this uh on capitol hill where do
they think stand uh on capitol hill to
try and get something done about this
now you're right this has been an issue
that people have been fighting for for
years and
a lot of times these bills just kind of
languish and die in congress and didn't
go anywhere in part because the
department of veteran affairs and the
department of defense argue that there's
no conclusive evidence that proves that
those toxic chemicals from the burn pits
are what caused the illnesses in the
veterans and it's a really high burden
of proof for those veterans to be able
to prove that and so now though this
year this congress there's a renewed
push and a renewed effort that is
getting a lot of attention the bill was
introduced by senators kirsten
gillibrand and marco rubio a democrat
and a republican that would give
benefits the presumption that they were
in fact exposed to those chemicals it's
similar to what was done after vietnam
and the gulf war with agent orange and
that would make it a lot easier for
these veterans to get health care
benefits and other benefits and it's
gotten a lot of attention comedian jon
stewart for example has come to capitol
hill to support this effort and talk
about the necessity to give veterans
this extra support and actually also
last year president
joe biden said that he believes that the
brain cancer that killed his son beau
biden was caused by exposure to those
same toxic chemicals from the burn pits
so it is an issue that's getting a lot
more attention now and the lawmakers who
are involved with this effort say that
they are hopeful that this time around
they will be able to pass something
successfully through congress so even if
there's some some bipartisan agreement
on this even if there's maybe resistance
from the department of defense is there
a price tag uh ballpark on how much
is needed to try and help these veterans
for their what they what they're dealing
with so that's something that the
actually the congressional budget office
would have to figure out and there's
been a lot of debate about what that
price tag would actually be because some
estimates say that about three and a
half million veterans um are believed to
have been exposed to the toxic chemicals
but what the supporters of these efforts
say is that you know not a lot not all
of those people would sign up or try to
get the benefits um a lot of veterans
are just hesitant even you know older
veterans with the agent orange we know
that there are a lot who were exposed
who didn't
file for claims or try to get benefits
and so
that's a question that's yet to be
answered and that's something that the
congressional budget office would figure
out if and when any of these bills do
move forward we'll see if it does move
forward alex simone thank you for
joining us from washington
four of the 911 terrorists were here in
las vegas in the months before the
attack 20 years ago but we've not never
gotten a clear answer why our george
knapp spoke with clark county sheriff
joe lombardo about what we know about
that visit
it's 20 years since 9 11 and i've
interviewed former sheriffs your
predecessors over the years about why
the terrorists visited our city
no one's ever really came up with an
answer what insight do you have what
thoughts do you have about why they were
here so many times i'm sure you've heard
all the
the theories you know throughout the
years
and
especially in close to the incident
some of the people surmising why they
were in las vegas but to answer your
question george i don't know exactly
what it is i have my own opinion and i
guess that's what you're asking of me
um
the theory associated with it it would
be a nondescript
uh
meeting place from individuals coming
from disparate parts of the united
united states
and without
people without being suspicious
i guess that would be the key word to
use um
individuals coming together ease of
coming together because of the the
numbers of tourists that come here from
all walks of life they wouldn't stick
out
be able to meet and then the other part
of the theory is is you know to conduct
some
activities that they weren't allowed to
either based on their religion or
personal beliefs and through martyrdom
they were able to cleanse their souls
associated with that so
uh that's the best analogy i could
provide you
from my personal opinion you know
speaking with your predecessors in
previous years uh you know they had said
prior to 9 11 las vegas was not really
considered to be a threat to
foreign terrorists jihadists um boy
things have really changed since then
right
yeah it has i mean we've had some
incidences occur without the public
knowledge
in las vegas that we were able to
interdict sooner before anything would
happen
um but then most of it hasn't been
foreign based it's been domestic based
um you know things that people are aware
of you know the millers associated with
officer beck and soldo um one october
uh
you know it wasn't classified as
terrorism i classified it as terrorism
domestic terrorism um but the under the
federal statute wasn't but
those type of incidents are occurring
within the continental us now as
compared to that
traditional mindset or that vision of
terrorists being from a foreign
foreign country perpetrating their their
crimes or their crisis
amongst the continental us
um talk to me about how 9 11 and
subsequent events changed metro you and
i have had the discussion before about
training things that changed in response
to not just 911 but other mass murder
events around the world right right um
well i think it was a watershed
event
in the the
the
gaps the deltas associated with the
intel world
you know how you could you get out of
the 911 report more importantly the most
salient issue and that was the lack of
information shared
the intel were was um bifurcated
trifurcated you know it was it had
tentacles going in every different
direction and nobody was talking with
each other and they discovered that
there was not pieces of knowledge
everywhere and if they had put it
together they probably could have
prevented 911. and so what had what has
occurred as a result of that is
you know internally in local law
enforcement counterterrorism units have
been stood up on their own without
having to rely strictly on the federal
space you know your federal partners to
provide
assistance in that space because a lot
of things that we think are suspicious
at the local level in the state level is
not considered
suspicious at the federal level so we
thought it was important for us to be
more proactive